I thought we should start with the
Zipcar story how did you come up with
this idea how did how did all this how
did all this happen
Zipcar is today the largest car sharing
company in the world and this was back
in the fall of 99 that we were founded
Mike what's interesting to reflect on is
this was an idea that came from
someplace else this was an idea that was
being executed in Europe since about the
mid 80s and my co-founder is German she
was sitting in a cafe she looked across
the street and saw a shared car she came
back to Cambridge said what do you think
of this so she was in in what city
Berlin she was in Berlin in Berlin
sitting in a cafe and she asked me
because I had a business background and
I'm a very honest person but I've told
the story now so many times it feels
apocryphal but I think it's true that
really a light bulb went on over my head
I said oh my god this is what the
Internet is made for sharing very
specific resources easily among lots of
people this is what Wireless is made for
getting that reservation from a server
directly to the car remember this is a
fall of 99 and this is what I personally
want because I had three children and a
husband and I lived in a dense metro
area with one car my husband would take
that car there's no way in hell and I
needed a car sometimes and you know I
didn't want to park it maintain it snow
shovel it any of that but I needed a car
sometimes and so it really did snap
together this is precisely what I want
when you were rolling Ansett car how did
you think about which markets would be
the most receptive and which ones would
be problematic what's amusing about that
question is I've also been asked you
know why did you start in Boston and I
started busking I lived here right there
was no fancy market analysis that went
into that but as we rolled out and even
within the city there was something
inherited right because you thought of
Zipcar because you lived there because
you knew would be a good match for weird
for your life it's true and so I did I'm
absolutely correct in that I think I was
the right person to hear that store at
the right time because I was a user and
I lived that environment so if we think
about even expanding within Boston and
to the next cities what we learned is
that Zipcar works in places where people
don't need a car to get to work and it
works best where the price of parking is
very high per month now one side is it
cars of
course you know cutting-edge technology
and totally now on the other sense is
playing into something that is as old as
the oldest cities right I mean the
sharing economy is not new to urban
spaces right I mean what is an urban
restaurant other than a shared kitchen I
think because you have you're saying
exactly what I tell people all the time
because they keep saying to me oh no
sharing this cultural things you do it
in your country you do it in your city
but in our country in our city shouldn't
I say you're crazy you have been sharing
since time immemorial exactly I'm
completely in agreement with something
so I thought about you know Zipcar when
I was a kid in New York in the 1970s and
you know you could you have had a one
reason why you couldn't had it is that
technological issues in terms of doing
it but the other issue is is the issue
of safety and with the car be okay when
you got it so I've this I've long had
this sort of fantasy going to pick up a
Zipcar in Times Square in 1977 and like
finding a dead body in the trunk and
that would make the whole experience
fairly fairly negative now of course
with the technology you now know who had
the car before and it would all be
fairly easy but but in some sense I tend
to think of it as the technology has
enabled us to share more stuff so I
completely so I wrote this book tears
Inc and when I was writing the book I
had to come up with what were the
specific things that were enabling this
kind of sharing and I would say precise
that technology has made the transaction
of sharing of dealing with small
individual parts trivial so finding
those individual things paying for those
individual things getting this access
like Zipcar the card is really fast and
importantly this ability to move from
trusting friends and trusting relatives
to trusting the next circle out of
friends of friends and strangers and
that is enabled by technology totally
new today with the ability to ratings
and commentaries and that and that is
something has transformed even since we
started a Zipcar
and I think that's one of the things
that has made the sharing economy
blossom people talk about the gig
economy and the platform economy in the
sharing economy and the on-demand
economy and for me all of those names
work but this book that I wrote was to
call it the fact that when we talk about
those were actually talking about this
brand new collaboration this partnership
between a large entity that I'm calling
the ink
that is doing all the things that big
companies do well so the dig economy is
forgetting that it's only enabled by the
platforms and the platform economy is
nothing zero if it didn't have this
myriad of diversity around it so it's
this brand new collaboration that for me
is what is exciting and thrilling about
the future and enables us to get the
best of these both worlds and if I think
about what I love about this particular
future vision of the city is its really
celebrating celebrating and getting
value out of people's individual
uniqueness and so it's it's this the
delightful amazing thing I feel like we
each have our own side to play and that
is enabled by the internet that now
makes this possible
you